[Music]
we can you just remove the chance so
yeah I just removed all the furniture
for my home yeah the chairs out of your
house you don't have one chair in your
house no we don't we just can't we
ground it so we ground live and that's
been amazing because you suddenly
discover there's like a hundred
different rest positions that you can
choose on the ground uh-huh and we have
one we're sitting down now right yeah
but there's like a hundred different
rest positions so what are the main
complaints I get to see when I'm when
I'm coaching somebody a movement or any
other discipline and it's I've got lower
back pain
I've got knee pain I've got neck pain
and you realize that they're all the
areas that really should be more stable
they have a mobility role but they have
a stability role and then you have areas
that are designed specifically to be
more mobile than they are stable so the
ankle joint mobility the hip joint
mobility and the three core spine more
mobility and so they're the areas that
should be mobile but unfortunately when
we let me sit down and wheezing couches
and the posture that you get within
account is you slouch right so we in
turn into a slouching couching typing
swiping organism and the problem is
there that then it wipes out those areas
that are designed for mobility and they
get stiff and then the areas that should
be stable and now getting more mobility
into them so when we talk about lower
backs essentially when the hip and the
mid-back I've kind of lost perception or
you've lost perception of their role and
therefore the lower back gets attacked
so the way we address is just take it to
the ground man and then suddenly it's
like wow look at look at all these
different positions I can be choosing
and that wipes out even things like
standing desks cuz standard loads of
hype around a standing desk at the
moment but it's just as detrimental to
to stand all day with crappy posture as
it is to sit with crappy posture you
know mm-hmm yeah if you're standing but
you're not adopting proper form then
you're doing harm you know when we talk
about form the danger is where it's a
wet form people start thinking ah I have
to tense my core and squeeze my glutes
and all this stuff but it's that's not
it it's basically going back to what is
a wild posture hunter-gatherers do not
tense their core and squeeze the gluts
while they're moving around nor does any
other animal on the planet what dogs
might do they just can't communicate
thanks Mike all right now I'm squeezing
my glutes you know I mean I just fit
not happening but it's that again what
hasn't changed for them is their
environment environment is still the
same they're still moving the same
through a landscape and they
hunter-gatherers specifically move
through a landscape don't really move
for it they become the landscape I mean
they don't see themselves as separate
from it it's not the standing or the
sitting it's the fact that those are
those are things that we do for extended
periods of time right like even the most
fit and I plead guilty this like I I'm
fit I go I work out every day I train
but then I'm sitting at a desk
even if I'm sitting in an ergonomic
chair I'm still sitting for hours and
hours and hours and sometimes I don't
get up and move around that much and so
yeah I have lower back issues I have
some sciatic issues you know if you're
scrolling and looking at your phone your
neck is tensed up like I know what that
feels like like this is these are you
know things that I think every single
human being is experiencing on some
level no matter how fit you are we're
all sitting too much but it's every sick
in because it's almost like we've we've
with fitting two groups here but every
single human being would mean also hum
together as you see I'm just saying I'm
talking about modern Western yes exactly
so we're in that so that's like I have
this thing there's 83 percent of the UK
and living in urban environments and
there's a status like they spend ninety
ninety five percent their time indoors
so that's one Wow okay you guys are
blessed too because your moods been on
an amazing trail and you have that
outdoor experience been in London it's
like sometimes people just sheltering
and only got to get away from what they
see is the elements let's say but let's
say they're ninety percent their time
indoors so 9/10 their time indoors how
do we how do we flip it how do we make
the indoors more nourishing again and so
that for me it has to be if 95 cent nine
spent my time is indoors how much of
that is am i spending sedentary how do I
change that and so that that's been the
biggest cue for me I went into Santander
and did a talk in there the asset
management team and it was the same
thing as soon as I arrived I met the
head of the team and I said it's your
responsibility the first thing is the
air quality in here it's terrible clean
up the air is pretty worse indoors and
is outdoors so put air purification
systems in here and then to the people
that had this their desk area or this is
your responsibility you either create a
growth-promoting desk area or a
compromising desk area it's a choice
right but here's how you can make the
changes to start with because a lot of
it people don't understand that there is
another way there is another choice that
they can be making so then it was that
okay you want HR department here they
wouldn't even let people hug in you know
you're not allowed to hug in the office
not so imagine all the happy hormones
you're getting oxytocin you have for
longer you get serotonin well hugging's
tricky these days yes it's really tricky
I guess it's how long you hold it for
and how uncomfortable it becomes but it
is it's a tough one and and so that was
to me that was like right the one thing
I got it stripped that but we can't do
that that's that's okay are we allowed
standing desks and there was one person
in that whole office that had us
standing there okay let's just go
through what you can be doing if you
have to sit right we set a timer 20
minute thing timer goes off you just
push your chair back and you hold your
desk and we just squat and you do like
three squats at the desk to reset the
posture and then I want you to walk from
one end of the building to the other and
then come back to your desk done and
every 20 minutes
every 20 minutes and then said to the
guy who leads the floor medi are you
okay with that he's like yeah man this
is cool and then right can the next
thing I'm going to all have a plant the
piece Liddy's really easy to keep so
easy you can go away for two weeks there
might be a bit droopy when you come back
be just a little bit water and then
they're up again and that will remove
benzene xylene formaldehyde from this
environment again so put that right on
your desk so then two women just rushed
out immediately run out for two piece of
lilies put them on their desk just sit
just simple little adjustments and again
it gives them something living in that
environment that they can then nurture
and they have to look after
what about lighting lighting is a you
know it's a big one for me um we as well
as not having you furniture in our house
we switched to remote-control bulbs and
amber lighting I should point out you
have three daughters yeah yeah what are
their ages knowing just about 10 10 just
about 10 8 3 year old a new one on the
way so they're they're young enough that
getting rid of the chairs is like a game
and probably fun but we were joking
earlier like fast-forward to them you
know being 2530 years old telling their
therapist that their dad make made them
take all the chairs out of that
well it's funny cuz when we moved
sharply trauma when we move to the beef
that we were just like hippies there
anyway it was fine and it was just and
then other people were doing the same
and now I have that people every time I
move into a new place I go and buy a
table from somewhere and I just take the
legs off cut the legs off yes very
Japanese where'd you get that table form
and I showed them the video that's what
I did so those people now Instagram me
to say so there if you might go uh-huh
there might be a new field for this ray
the trauma of the ground living
population but she just squat around the
dinner table or sinister we again we see
one rest position there's there's
multiple we're going to go through them
and later because it helped just unravel
stuff from my run but there's kneeling
positions there's positions called shin
boxes and you can just flip from one to
the next like a mobility session so
rather than us going to yoga and doing
flexibility work we just ground live
because again I don't see
hunter-gatherers do mobility work and
yoga but they're amazing specimens again
so it's what are they doing so he
stripped it back are they grounded
okay so let's round it and what's been
different is each child has been growing
that Lola was familiar with city seating
furniture sitting furniture Millie was
about to when we ditched the furniture
so for her it's not really in motor
there is kind of you know whereas
Tallulah was born without any furniture
in the home we carried her everywhere
she never got I never had a car seat
never had a stroller always in a carrier
we did no nappies with her so she had no
nappy you do that
waitjust we have more trust in that with
dogs and cats we have loads of trust in
them right we get them litter trays and
they poop in it and then they're done
without babies we keep them in nappies
for four years now it's like the most
intelligent species we perceive
ourselves the most intelligent species
yet we don't put any trust in our babies
and it's a relationship between Katarina
to start with and the baby
Katarina's my wife by the way and and
and she'd built this amazing
relationship that whenever the baby
would make a signal she'd know the baby
needs to go where Tallulah needed to go
to the toilet and then eventually that's
then passed on to all of us because we
can see her signals and given the chance
that innate ability because the baby's
picking are they're listening to me how
they're listening to me the signal gets
stronger and the signal gets so strong
that the baby knows our node you go to
and then eventually and I think that ten
mops she stood up super stronger boom
not a toddler not rolling around but
strong and then occasionally what we
again we lived out in the Sun so we had
terracotta tiles on the floors
occasionally should do a poop on the
floor but at ten months already she was
going off grabbing a cloth and then
wiping up her mess you know it was just
simply just again another level that I
think I could see it in their movement
because obviously we removed the
furniture she was rock climbing at 12
months is like people were like what's
going on this night child's insane and
barefoot running they can all barefoot
run they run over anything just like I
do and again it's not again it's just
their innate abilities I haven't I
haven't dumbed it down in a way haven't
DMS domesticated their movement I've
always just nurtured it and instead of
saying get down from there I teach them
how to climb you know my fear doesn't
get in the way
katarina occasion you had it you know oh
my god they're really close to the edge
and I said no code we have to go to the
edge with them and we have to guide them
and explain things to them but don't hit
them with our what's near the edge
because guess what I'm gonna want to
know what's over the edge of someone
reacts like that generally so Caterina's
totally on board did you meet her when
you were already like well on this path
or you know like what's her relationship
with all the stuff that you do um I met
Catarina she blew my mind because I had
a Pilates practice years ago um in a
health club I've had a big space and
Pilates practitioners and and then I had
a separate perception it was in the
health club and then there was the main
reception of the health club so every
now and then I'd come out to my
reception check what was going on with a
diary and who was in and and then I
looked across and there was this
beautiful woman standing on the desk
house ah my friend who's there I've
gotta go and ask her who she is you know
and um he said I think she's new okay so
whenever I just said look hey um can you
go and get a piece of paper and a pen
and she was like okay I'll [ __ ] her in
OP she went and got a piece of paper a
pen I just came back so can you just
write your number down I'll take you out
and that was it and we went out to
dinner and I took her to this is a while
back now and I didn't know at the time I
took her to Goucher grill so I took her
to Goucher grill and we sat on cowhide
chairs and ordered a ridiculous steak
as I was doing at that particular time
when was that eleven years ago and she
looked really uncomfortable and I said
you okay said yeah I'm a vegan so then
we got around it I ordered some amazing
caramel young and mushrooms and a dish
and that was fine and we and and we hit
it off and it was amazing and then over
time I've always said that Katarina was
far more connected than I was and I was
almost trying to get to a position where
she was so she was heavily influenced by
yoga but there were things going on with
her in within our own digests digestion
through what I'd say was a poor vegan
diet at that time those are grains and
pulses and that was it and guided by I
think her student know if she was
studying psychology at the time she's
from Slovakia so she was converting her
master's in psychology into a UK degree
and was working behind reception while
studying and being a nanny so she was
like I was just in or you know this is
incredible and yeah as a sailor I've
always felt like God but I was I was
having tea I was trying to get to her
level
[Music]